hi how's everything in the dark
kidnapping business getting you dog why
were you walking him Charisse one I do
not want that image in my head too could
you come get my dog back looking for a
little Shih Tzu's and some other Punk
kill those Punk's except blood
it's his puke you want to go to the
bathroom please some of the bloggers the
puke off yeah
I almost got killed today because you
kidnapped the wrong dog are you serious
Wow what I'm gonna do we could take on
all bad guys maybe in the desert what do
you think we should do in real life how
you doing what up get you back to your
daddy in a day or two don't be sad paw
paw no paw
that's okay - they're gonna pull myself
together I know it's gonna end up killed
you're not pulling yourself together are
you dog the piece the entire object get
down put your hands up no I've got a gun
okay this is my case it's too bad
I'm gonna work are you pissed at me for
something baby why would I be pissed at
you Maddy because you're a killing
waiting for somebody old guy no okay you
seem normal
come on in we got to get this dog off
the street because it's kidnap for a
maniac dandy I like it
it's got layers an eye for an eye leaves
the whole world blind no he doesn't
they'll be one guy left with one eye
how's the last blind guy gonna take out
the eye of the last guy left